real quick let me show you the
Counterpoint on this so Dan Crenshaw
who's also from Texas which is
interesting because obviously chip Roy
is a congressman from Texas as well
here's Crenshaw giving the opposing
point on sort of why you should go with
McCarthy we all served in different ways
but we mostly served for the same reason
so that we would take the fight to the
enemy and the enemy would not no longer
take the fight to the American people we
had purpose we had mission that was our
mission we have Mission up here some
people have different priorities some
people want to cut spending some people
want to fix our mandatory spending
problems some of us want to fix the
Border deal with the Mexican drug
cartels that are murdering tens of
thousands of Americans a year by
poisoning them with fentanyl there's a
lot of missions that we have up here I
don't think that the American people
care about any of these so-called
missions happening this week
rules changes who gets more power who
gets on what committee I can't think of
one American who gives a damn about any
of that
they care about the mission
and the conservative agenda is one that
will accomplish the mission for the
American people the best but we can't
start that agenda until we start
governing that's why we're up here
because we care about Mission we care
about service and we care about the
American people we care about getting
things done
Carol what do you think about that take
that it's sort of like suck it up you 20
like we've got the majority it'll be
better than the other guys let's just
play through something to that effect so
so I don't understand the idea that this
is somehow embarrassing that democracy
is embarrassing like oh how embarrassing
not everybody agrees and especially the
left saying it to us like oh how
humiliating you guys don't agree on
everything
um I I hate all of that that's like
ridiculous to me and what I think
Crenshaw is wrong about here is that
Americans do understand what is
happening go to any conservative chat
group on the internet they know what is
happening in Congress they understand
this battle they really do and yes they
want the bigger agenda passed absolutely
but they want the people in charge who
will be most accountable for passing
that agenda and it look there's so many
personality driven things here like the
fact that Trump supports Kevin McCarthy
that's so big in the background of this
like his supporters are like kind of not
going along with what he wants but by
his supporters I mean trumps and they
want somebody new and they also want
somebody held people held accountable
for the the losses that happen in this
last election and they want leadership
change and that's not crazy that's not
embarrassing that's not humiliating and
it's okay that we all are giving it out
I love by the way I should just add love
that John cardillo is being called a
rhino on Twitter I find that it's
unbelievable I'm a big squish Rhino I'm
being called Dan Crenshaw light that was
one of my favorite I can't even stand
the guy so happy yes that's actually
hilarious it's one thing if I get called
a rhino but cardillo like something
really ain't right the biggest
dissonance I mean this is right up there
with people saying like cardillo he
doesn't go hard in the paint you know
that's not a guy that really throws down
on the right I'm like ah go back go back
at his Twitter feed like a month and
tell me and tell me who else is is
throwing the kind of punches that John
but anyway put that aside for a second
somehow there's just this carve out
where it's fine for Donald Trump to push
for McCarthy and this is where I say to
people come on now come on now if we're
going to do this thing where they're
going to fillet people on Twitter uh
about how their their squishes and their
fakes and by the way I haven't come I'm
I'm a proud fence sitter on this issue
I'm like look I think there could be a
better speaker I think McCarthy would
probably be more or less you know maybe
with some concessions okay I don't
really care I actually think I agree
with actually a lot of what what
Crenshaw said about how this doesn't
really I agree that it doesn't really
matter I don't think it's fair that
people don't know what's going on but I
don't think it changes all that much
um but the fact that Trump is able to
come out in favor and basically tell
everybody we'll vote for McCarthy and no
one's saying well Trump is a rhino
squish who's a big Trump supporter I
mean that just goes to show you here
that I think people this is about
emoting if you'd like more sane takes on
our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell